I really wish I only had three toes cuz  then I get a discount all pedicures is  that a deal in desert  it sure is except for people in the  pedicure big walk-in maybe like hose  this huh I'm dissing cuz he got so  missing what the [ __ ] it's not worth my  time yeah it ain't worth your time  it ain't worth your mine I got three  toes  I used to have nine plus one three toes  it's way more fun  you only got thirty percent of the work  to be done  used to chill only three toes you gotta  feel I know it'd be gross but you could  do it for muscle memory and yeah up here  do you make the soaps on the TV we fix  my feet we can watch soap but your feet  is not dope and you should know that you  need more hope I have less than ten so